c'est officiel nos stars favorites ont
l'âge d'avoir des enfants est prof que
nous vieillissons ses enfants ont l'âge
d'être sur internet c'est le cas par
exemple de jade smet la fille de johnny
et laeticia hallyday est à peine 16 ans
enflamme déjà instagram et tik tok avec
tes photos où elle pose en influence aux
modes doux en star sexy au bord de l'eau
même chose pour et matmut vie de david
hallyday qui à 23 ans utilisent des
réseaux pour prolonger son métier de
mannequin des défis des modes au like
instagram une jeune femme qui cartonne
mais qui n'est pas encore aussi comique
que la fille de vanessa paradis et
johnny depp
lily rose à 21 ans la jeune fille cumule
déjà plus de 4 millions de followers qui
lie quotidiennement ces photos du
shooting de tournage
une fois n'est pas coutume les garçons
de stars aussi s'affiche sur les réseaux
c'est le cas de rené charles angeli le
fils de céline dion qui a 20 ans poste
lui aussi son quotidien de jeune homme
et musiciens sur les réseaux des enfants
stars qui sans marcher dans les traces
de leurs parents tout en tentant de se
faire eux aussi un nom
et ouais quoi
samedi comment voir son à simon castaldi
notamment grandes stars sur les réseaux
sociaux l'ont écouté deux stars j'ai
toujours dit que les stars excusez moi
je passe à une star on va réserver je
vous emmerde
on va réserver le mot star pour céline
dion et barbie démarche au pour un peu
le melon d'eau pour alain delon
aujourd'hui jardin mais mettons ça
m'horripile the most arpente le monde
on est pas des stars joe doucette on a
un petit à petit extrait de pilonner
smet a pourquoi parce que les athlètes
damas dément est très jolie j'ai un
groupe de 3,4 gym notre amour est aussi
dû regarder
hop là
m
je ne sais pas
à
bah
monsieur
je
[Musique]
c'est pas tomber
elana smet
c'était une grosse valeur maintenant sur
la wii oui oui oui elle est allée très
bankable parce que l aele et très chic
elle est très jolie elle est très classe
elle elle incarne la beauté à la carte
plein de choses sur les réseaux sociaux
et ben ouais et ben dis-donc mais je
trouve ça génial et en même temps c'est
vrai que ça peut donner le tournis fait
même pas une d'argent ça va très vite et
c'est vrai que pour l'instant son son
talent on ne connaît pas encore vraiment
quoi donc s'il ya un bien un décalage
quoi vous savez les réseaux sociaux
c'est un vrai talent arrive à accrocher
des gens sur les réseaux sociaux avec
des photos des textes des story et que
c'était aller au travail au quotidien on
dit ce qu'on veut mais je suis désolé
c'est un vrai job et c'est un vrai
talent pour moi de pouvoir maintenir les
gens auprès de vous tous les jours qui
vous suivent quelle est la proportion de
gens qui suivent les enfants de stars
pour ce qu'ils sont et pas pour leur
part en moi quand je suis le fils de
céline dion ceci pour voir un peu
l'univers de céline dion tu comprends le
truc ringard
[Applaudissements]
bien qu'assez
non mais là tu dis c'est vrai qu'il
serait qu'on en a pris beaucoup par pau
pour la fille de johnny damon a appris
beaucoup sur sa mère il ya merci des
conneries